i still have to kind of stay strong and
it seems somewhat dangerous for
most the roles i play right but i'm
never gonna look like john cena
you know who can look like john cena
john cena john cena he's the only one
he's [ __ ] amazing he's he's a machine
your relationship is so awesome in that
it's so ridiculous you know what it's so
great don't we have great great
chemistry great chemistry you know james
didn't even know that
james gunn didn't even know that when we
got cast really no you asked him
he he said to me i see you he saw me an
hbo peacemaker hbo uh perry mason right
and he started thinking about me over
the pandemic you know he was watching
perry mason he thought about me for this
role
he started writing the role for me for
peacemaker that was the impetus for him
and when we had our zoom meeting we had
a zoom meeting that's how that's how
that's how that went down he said i said
you know i've worked with john
he said i didn't know that i said oh
yeah i played a villain opposite him in
his first film
wow and he went really and i said and
and i said
i said as a matter of fact
we have good chemistry because we
actually get along this is before you
started filming this yeah i hadn't seen
john in like 10 years
uh i worked with him on psych was
another episode we did we did a thing on
you did psych i did say i think two
episodes was julie and yeah james
they've been on here a couple times i
hope i i think they like me great guys
they had me on i i don't really know i'm
sure i i had great fun working with them
um
uh
but uh uh
john and i uh i think
he i brought my son to see him wrestle a
couple times i'd love it and john uh
john was super cool with my son my son
maybe you know he's 21 now maybe 10
years ago he was 10. my son was like
going to wrestling academy with luke
perry son out here in the valley rick
drazen's school and uh
and john did this thing
i think it was in arizona summerslam or
something or something or other
he knew where we were where we were
sitting we were sitting right closer he
had arranged it
and he came into the ring with all that
you know that stuff that he does
and he slid across
the ring
came through the ropes and leaned over
and took his hat off and plopped it on
my son's head
and then went back up on stage and
started wrestling
he was like wow the coolest [ __ ]
intro i've ever seen that is remarkable
and my son was just like
you know you've been touched by thor i
mean you know you know it's like it was
an amazing thing that's amazing what a
sweetheart so we have a great we have a
great relationship that's great i hope
john says the same thing because i think
we do i think we have a really good uh
chemistry and i think it works really
well yeah i think it's wonderful